this is gonna be really tough it's gonna
be a lot harder than me haha alright I'm
gonna put down the camera and help so we
live here in Los Angeles like we had the
mountains move right up the hill and
then the beach right down the hill I'm
gonna see if I can get two of my
co-workers to drive up to Big Bear with
me and then drive down to the beach and
the same day to build a sandcastle and a
snowman hopefully we can get up there
make it happen and come back before
sunset
there we go we discussed our game plan
over breakfast are you serious do we
have rules Bertha let's go man
the snowmen should at least come up to
our hit we have to make sure it has a
carrot a hat and a little like scarf
because we don't want to get cold out
there right obviously thank you features
right face eyes eye is it a smile
or just a melancholy life well let's see
the boom is Sonia okay
[Music]
Maggie's over there making a great
little base no shadow there's a little
body that I'm working on over here what
time late it's late okay bye we're
behind on time we should already be like
Midway by now right because we got to
leave in like half an hour all right I'm
gonna put down the camera and help
[Music]
Harvey Oh Harvey Harvey smell me I
honestly had low hopes for us but this
is pretty great
it's only 1029 you finished with a
minute to spare yeah one minute to spare
yeah I'm gonna Boop him yeah let's get
out of it yeah yeah we gotta go
[Music]
like Herbie turned out better than I
thought I miss her already
so the rules for the Sandcastle are that
we have to have an exterior wall and at
least two tiers in the middle all before
censored yeah perfect
how hard could that be yeah I say those
are famous last words if we finish this
in under an hour I will run into the
ocean we need to walk me through the
plan here just look for it right like
that put a shock to go from mountain to
dance
not give an engine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we did I thought they were going to be
releasing
really a really dinky fantastic but we
figured out and what more than sunset
how beautiful is that
3 2 1
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]